alors que lyon accueillait ce mercredi
la cérémonie des victoires de la musique
classique dans l'auditorium de lyon
plusieurs collectifs ont voulu marquer
le coup à l'occasion du déplacement de
la ministre de la culture roselyne
bachelot spectacle improvisé devant
l'entrée ou encore occupation de
l'auditorium pendant les répétitions
mardi soir filipe vieira gérant de salle
de danse à lyon et restaurateurs s'est
installé devant l'auditorium avec une
troupe de danseurs et un cercueil
symbolisant la mort de l'art ils
demandent au gouvernement des solutions
adéquates s'agit pas d'ouvrir sans
respecter aucun geste barrière message
ou pas d'ouvrir manière égoïste on
prendre en compte la situation sanitaire
du pays
il s'agit de trouver des solutions et
c'est le boulot du golan en amont de
nous trouver des solutions à nous pour
qu'on puisse couvrir si la belgique le
fait 1 on peut le faire
filipe vieira plaide pour une
réouverture des salles de danse et lieux
culturels comme cela va se faire en
belgique à partir de mi mars face à
l'auditorium
une délégation du collectif unitaire 69
qui défend les intérêts des
intermittents de l'emploi et des
précaires du monde du spectacle
des milliers de personnes qui ne
bénéficient pas du statut d'intermittent
et dont de l'année blanche celle ci
expire en août 2021 le collectif en
demandent la prolongation
on demande nous la prolongation de
l'année blanche qui finit en 2021
on demande que healy vraie ouverture des
salles de spectacle puisque l'on
commencé à voir des études qui tombe sur
le fait que ce n'est pas des lieux de
contagion et on demande également que le
travail de répétition de tous les
artistes soient rémunérées voilà on
demande aussi le maintien des droits
sociaux savoir maladie congés
congé maladie
maternité etc avant la cérémonie
roselyne bachelot a rencontré une
délégation du collectif unitaire 69 et
de la cgt du spectacle
une rencontre qui n'a mené à aucune
avancée concrète
la troupe a remballé ses affaires juste
avant le début du couvre-feu à 18 heures
afin de s'éviter une contravention de
135 euros par personne